Yeah. Oh, I think I'm live.
I think I'm alive.
Hello world. It's Raj. I'm alive.
Okay.
Um,
all right.
Is there anybody in here? Oh, there's
some people in here. Hi Guys. Hi Guys.
I'm doing my live two and a,
a live Q and a.
I'm to saying that from Twitter right
now. I'm going and I'm back. Okay.
It's a shared it and now I'm going
to be here with you guys engaged.
We're going to start talking it. Hi
everybody. Hi. Hi. Hi. Welcome. Hello.
I'm going to name off some names.
I'm just doing this live Q and a for you
guys because I want to engage you guys.
Um, I'm going to name off
some names to start off with.
Niton Albert's Henry biggish Rafael,
both Don Tyshawn,
Alex Grazia, one Cortez. I'm preaching.
We've got a lot of cool
people in the room right now.
This week I'm going to do a live Q and
a. Okay. This is just a simple Q and a.
Next week, what I'm working on
is a setup for a, a more um, uh,
better live stream with the green
screen and you know, the code,
it's going to be much, much
better. Okay. So, but this
week, you know, we were trying,
I had a friend from upload VR come over
and help me try to set up the studio for
that, but we just couldn't do it right
now. So we have to buy a few things.
But next week we're going to do a full on,
you know,
we're going to start doing like
a full on weekly live streams.
The live streams are coming back
as you can see right now. Okay. So,
okay. So what I want
to do is do a Q and. A.
So any questions you have about deep
learning about blockchain, about me,
about anything. Uh, you can
talk about, this is my place,
just to be completely open
with you. I just moved in. Uh,
this is my place in San Francisco.
That's my studio back there.
If you want to take a look back
there. Uh, but yeah, this is me.
This is where I live.
I don't want to get too personal.
Tell everybody the address and stuff,
but it's where I am. What is, okay.
Are you going to visit pie con
ball can be this November. No.
How does start with machine
learning with minimal coding?
I have a great video on this.
Search on Youtube.
SAROJ learn machine learning three months.
Xavier asks,
when should I apply for fall internships
starting from August and ending in
December.
The best time to apply for
full internships is the
beginning of the summer.
So I would say Jew. What are
opportunities after learning blockchain?
So once you start,
once you've learned blockchain,
there's no way to say you've learned
a blockchain because it's actually a
continuously changing field. This is a
field that has heavy researched. Okay.
People are constantly researching
how to improve blockchain.
What are things that are
working with blockchain?
So once you feel like you have
a good grasp of what it is,
then the best thing would be to start
working on business use cases, provenance,
um, uh, working on anytime there's a
third party that is very expensive,
you can remove that middleman. And you
could say businesses, a lot of money.
So insurance, um, security.
I'm a great trailer that talks about
the 20 different use cases for this.
Literally 20 of them.
Search blockchains to Raj,
what hair product you use. I don't use
any hair products. It's all natural.
I swear to you. I don't use
any, I mean I use shampoo. Okay.
But like I don't use anything to like
make it stick out. That's just my life.
This hair is alive.
Mark 10 asks,
how do I improve my
coding skills? Um, you,
the best way to improve your coding
skills is to continuously code.
So there's this challenge,
it's called a hundred days of code
and a lot of my friends have done this
challenge.
What that means is every single day you
add a pull request to a repository up
your own or some other project on get hub.
So what I want you to do is every single
day and make a pull request on Github.
Guys,
speaking of get up,
I had some amazing get up content
coming out this week starting tomorrow.
I'm so excited to show you guys and
stuff. It's some hits, amazing stuff. Um,
Tyler Berry asks,
is there any benefit to
doing image recognition tasks
with color spaces outside
of RGB?
I Dunno if there's a benefit,
but if the data set is not RGB based,
then that would be the best thing to do.
I have a great video on this.
It's called, it's, it's actually called
Yolo. So search yellow object detection.
And in the beginning of the video
I go through all the different, um,
all the different strategies for
computer vision that came before yellow.
And in there you're going to find what
you're talking about. Martin asks,
what is 100 days of code exactly.
Just,
it's a Hashtag just search for a hundred
days of code on Google. But it's, it's,
it's, it's a, it's a, it's like a
challenge that developers are ebbing,
giving themselves to get
better at programming by
coding every day for a hundred
days.
Honeoye asks,
do a phd and ml without a CS degree.
It's possible. It's very hard.
But it's possible to get accepted to a
school to do a phd without having a CS
degree.
You're going to have to have published
something in the field or done something
that is very useful for them
to accept you. Right. And uh,
and a great way to do this, to be
real with you guys because of course,
and we're real, is to find one of
these professors at a school, you know,
just like shoot, you know, like get
along with them, you know, like, uh,
meet them for dinner. Yeah, you've
got to, you got to keynote escalate.
Not Keno escalate, but
like social escalates, that
physical relationship. Listen,
some of the people who I know,
I'm going to just,
I'm going to name a name right
here at Taryn southern. Okay.
So Karen southern is a youtube
creator who dropped an AI music video.
Now if I dropped an AI music video,
it would do well.
But when Tara and dropped it,
the New York Times covered it.
A bunch of these famous
outlets covered it.
And the reason is because she's so good
at making these connections with people.
And really when it comes down to
whether it's selling yourself,
selling your code,
selling your product,
if you know how to build these
relationships with powerful people,
that is what really matters in the end.
So when I meet with the,
the reason I even went on that tangent
is because if you meet one of the
professors at these schools, um, and
you don't have a cs degree, if they,
if they like you, then they can
open doors for you. So, you know,
email them directly, cold email, trying
to meet up with them for dinner, just,
you know, escalate the relationship
and then it can you, you'll,
you'll be more likely to get in.
Okay.
Uh, cool. Asks,
can teenagers who haven't taken
calculus or statistics yet,
learn and machine learning and how,
listen, um, machine learning, okay.
I'm just going to say it as deep learning.
Deep learning is creating models
using linear, how's your bro?
And then optimizing those
models with calculus.
So his calculus necessary
for machine learning, 100%.
It is very necessary.
Do you need to take an entire calculus
course before, uh, doing machine learning?
The answer is no. You know
why? Because Michelle,
it only takes small parts of calculus.
It takes, you have to use a derivative,
you have to use the partial derivatives.
Now these are very crucial
concepts in calculus. However,
do you need to use the integral, another
part of Calculus? It's very crucial. No,
right?
So you don't have to use all of calculus.
You only have to use certain part of
Calculus and what I would say is learn
calculus as you need to while
you're learning machine learning.
Don't just sit there and say
by a calculus textbook and say,
one day I wanted learn machine learning,
but first I'm going to try learning
calculus. No. Learn machine learning.
Do something.
Find a project that excites you can
along the way you will learn the calculus
and what we're talking about.
Calculus. Let's just say this.
The most important technique that is
calculus base that you need to know is
gradient descent.
And Luckily for you,
I have a great video on this search
gradient descent Saroj on Youtube.
The best video you will
find on backpropagation and
gradients is sent on Youtube
and everything will start making
sense in terms of calculus. Ray Asks,
I am 13 years old and I finished my
artificial intelligence standard degree.
That wasn't actually a question.
I just read that out.
PMM pinned the asks, can you make money
predicting stocks with machine learning?
Listen to me,
God's not a lot of people,
you know when it comes to making money
with machine learning using stock price
prediction,
a lot of people are very interested in it,
but notice you won't find a
lot of tutorials on this. Why?
Because the people who have figured this
out are not going to tell people there
are secrets, right? If you
have, if you work at Blackstone,
if you work with her black rock,
if you work at JP Morgan,
if you work at ing,
any of these big banks,
you are being paid as a quantitative
analyst to create predictive models.
That is their job. That is
in their job description. I,
it is without a doubt in my mind that
a lot of these traders and hedge fund
people,
they have models that are greater than
50% in their accuracy for predicting the
next stock price,
but they're not gonna share it.
So what you need to do is reverse
engineer what they're doing by taking into
account sentiment analysis,
what's happening in the news,
what people are talking
about on social media,
and then combine all of those
data points into a single model.
A Mariah is a great place to find, uh,
models that are current in his space.
Real Patel asks, how can we get best
results in real time? Deep fakes.
Okay,
so the best result for real time d fakes.
Uh,
I don't know what you mean by best.
You have to be very specific, right?
So you have to be very specific in your
questions with me with machine learning
engineers,
with people in the field.
Because anytime you are ambiguous and
this is just a good practice to have,
you're going to get the wrong answer.
But I'm going to assume I best.
You mean fastest.
So right now there is not a
real time solution to defects.
Would this be an amazing technology?
Yext,
could you make a lot of money if you made
an app that did this in the cloud? Yes.
Has anyone done this before? No. Is
this a possibility for moneymaking? Yes.
Uh,
deep face by the way is taking a video
and it takes a lot of processing power,
but taking the video and then adding in
the face of someone else in real time to
this video.
So like Nicholas Cage,
the Internet has day having
a lot of fun doing this. Uh,
report it from the Hollywood reporter
came and interviewed me about this.
But this is very,
this is a very hot thing right now and
not just in machine learning but in the
world right now.
Uh,
okay.
I did too. Asks, do you recommend
getting a postdoc Postgrad degree,
four ml masters or phd or
he's an Undergrad degree
in cs and math can now I do
not recommend getting a phd in machine
learning. I'm going to say that right now.
I do not recommend it unless you're
going to like a top by school.
Like if you're wanting to Stanford,
yes. Do not forsake that opportunity.
If you're going into like University
of Phoenix or like, you know,
not like a really good college,
don't even do it because you can get a
lot of those resources. Thinking about,
just like, think of, you
know, how Elon Musk says,
think of things from first principles.
What are like those sub
modules of a university degree
that are useful? You know,
you want the advisement in advisory roles,
you need an advisor,
you need resources, you
need, um, a learning path.
All of those things you can find online.
You can find an advisor online.
You can find resources, might,
you could channel online,
you can find a learning path online
through via these courses. You can do,
look at my courses.
You can make your own course.
So as long as you have those three
things, you don't necessarily need to, uh,
you know, to commit to a phd
because it is quite a commitment.
I five to seven year commitment.
Uh, and a lot of advisors,
they're not really good. You know, they've
been coasting. They got it, got this. Um,
what, how do I say it? They
have this, um, um, you know,
these metals and these like
award.
So they've gotten into it feel like good.
So you need like a really hungry adviser.
Um,
corporate sinks says hello.
Emiliano says,
are you into some personal AI project?
Emilio?
Right now there are 15
businesses that you know,
are possible from this community.
Um, you know, there's Q and a,
there's consulting, there's hiring
opportunities, there's a school of Ai,
there's a lot.
And I just want to focus on building or
making my videos and teaching you guys
how to Code and teaching you guys
machine learning and blockchain.
So that's what I'm focused on.
However,
I do have a business partner
that's focused on, you know,
making these things happen.
And it's essentially,
this is becoming a very large empire
and it's paying for all of this. So,
you know, we've got a
good space here, but, uh,
I'm focused on the videos on youtube. You
guys are my focus. I want to, you know,
help you guys become amazing at machine
learning at life, at everything.
Soft skills, hard skills. So that's,
that's my goal is, is helping you guys.
That's my number one goal in
life right now. Go Ku has,
how good is Google Colab?
So go cool.
I have an amazing Goku thank you
for saving the world from uh,
the Chevron Dragon by the way,
back in the day.
And thank you for dying for all of our
sins, you know, thank you. Go. I love you,
but I'm dragonball z forever. Well,
what was even the question? Damn,
I should've like there's,
you guys should see this.
There is so much text happening right now.
Uh, thank you ru tool. Marco,
ask where and what do you do right now?
I live in San Francisco, California.
I am focused on creating technical
content for the world for you guys.
And that is my number one goal. So that
just creating technical videos and then,
um, there's, there's
more out, more at there.
Bob, Don asks, can you talk about how
to find incubators for your startup?
You know, there are, um,
how to find incubators is a good question.
So I'd been a part of a
couple of incubators. Um,
what I am very hesitant to do is to ever
give equity to an incubator unless it's
like y Combinator. Okay. So
because I'm actually in general,
very picky about giving
away equity. So, uh,
so yeah,
I mean you want to look for a deal where
they are giving you more than you are
giving them. Um, ideally, and now what I
would do is just like pay the, you know,
the rent, you know, pay some
liquid cash to the incubator,
not give away equity and
um, you know, also the,
the quality of the incubator, your
independence on the city you're in, right?
So if you're in some western country
or China or actually even in Bombay,
there, there's likely like at least two
or three really good incubators. Um,
Deli, not so much, sorry, Delhi.
Uh, but um, and also in south India,
in Bangalore as well.
It depends on the city you're in,
but all that is to say if you have a
team of, if you're more than yourself,
definitely join an incubator. If it's
just you, she's trying to coworking space,
find people.
Um,
Edgar masks. Do you know something
about, oh, the questions already gone.
There's so many questions coming in
right now. Hello from Kenya. Hi Kenya.
I love you.
How do you know mega mega sell asks,
how do you know when
you're ready for freelance?
How do you know when you're ready
for freelance? Let me ask you this.
Are you making money? If the answer is
yes, do you keep doing what you're doing?
If the answer is no, you're
ready for freelance. Okay.
When I started doing freelance work,
I was living in a hacker house
with 12 guys in one room. Okay?
So that was in one room with 12 bunk beds.
I W I had like three k USD and my bank
account, I needed some money. Okay.
I needed to hustle.
So the way to do freelance is to
just start doing freelance. Okay.
Learn what you need to along
the way. Don't listen to
anybody else that you know,
all of your ability is in your head.
You know what you tell yourself
you can and you cannot do.
I got into the robotics lab at Columbia
because I applied for a position as a
Gpu, um, intern. Essentially. I don't,
I didn't know anything about Gpu,
but you can bet that once I
got there and I had the job,
I stayed in late every night to learn
how the GPU works and learn how Kuda
programming worked.
And then eventually,
uh,
eventually we, I did it. I spent up,
they've feature classification for
the Da Vinci surgical robot by 800%.
So you will,
you will move mountains if you,
if you just put yourself in
an uncomfortable position
where you have to do well,
you will move mountains, I promise
you. All right. So, um, Christian.
Hey Christian,
I recognize your name.
I feel like I'm getting nowhere
trying to get data science, jobs,
advice Christian. I have
three, not just one,
three amazing videos on this exact
thing coming out for you this weekend.
But all that is to say in one sentence,
if you're getting nowhere,
I would s I would start with the people
you know and the people that they know
because clearly they're not giving you
some jobs because they don't trust you.
You haven't built your brand enough.
Like you want to get to the point where
you are constantly saying no to people.
Okay. That's where I'm at. I am
constantly saying no to brands.
There's so many brands in the
pipeline into it and video, Google,
every single tech company you
could think about is reaching out.
There's too many for me to
be thinking about, right?
I just want to make videos and that's
why I'm building essentially an empire of
people who are helping me out
with this stuff. But that's how,
where you want to be. So I was
focused on building your brand, right?
Through technical tutorials,
through creating, um,
code on get hub that other developers
want to be a part of. And you know,
just working on your marketing.
Again,
I have some great videos on that this
weekend. So that's what I would say.
If you're, if you're not getting any
leads, we'll ml replaced programmers.
That's the most hilarious question
ever. No, of course. Listen,
if machine learning replaces programmers,
you can bet it will replace
everybody else. Okay.
Machine learning is not
going to replace programmers.
We're going to go on a little walk
together because I need to get a, uh,
a charger for my laptop.
No machine machine learning is
never going to replace programmers.
This is my studio, by the
way. I'll go into my studio
studio. We're setting it up,
you know,
got a lot of stuff.
We as in me and my friend who I'm
doing contract work, you know, he's,
he's doing production for me by the way.
Product,
contract work is the future guys, by the
way, don't just trying to think of like,
oh, I need a guy and he's going to be
full time. And you know, that's it.
You know, the contract
work is a future. You know,
we all went options as millennials,
as people who are in the 21st century.
No one wants to commit to anything.
So don't be afraid to build an entire
company based off of contract work alone.
Okay? So you're going to need
help. And here's the other thing.
I started this youtube channel. I
didn't even think like, you know,
I didn't think like, oh, I want to
build a company. I want to be a manager.
I want to be in charge. No, I just,
I didn't even know what I was doing.
I just knew I wanted to
add value to the world.
And if you try to add value to the world
yourself, people will come to LP. Okay.
What do we got here? Oh man,
there's so many good questions.
I wish you guys could see this.
You will. Thanks to youtube.
Thank you youtube for adding the, uh,
comments and in the post, you know,
once I post this video,
uh, Danny had, it's gone.
She vom asks his master's
necessary for a good ml job. No.
Uh,
six bay asks,
Does Your University
matter or your degree?
Now I'm going to tell you the real answer.
And not a lot of people will say this
because they want to make you feel good.
Yes, your university matters.
Okay. Because it's a brand,
right?
Every brand you associate yourself
with with matters for your brain.
Right? So whether it's a university,
whether it's an employer,
whether it's a person,
you know,
people can be brands to think about
things in terms of brands and who you
associate yourself with. Right? I
associated myself with a lot of brands,
but I only talk about a few. Right?
Because I talked about those top brands,
that people that are most recognizable,
that have the most respect,
surely how tool asks, how, how do you
manage your time? That's a great question.
Um,
so I manage my time by waking up everyday
at 8:00 AM and going to my coworking
space and drinking some coffee
and just making videos, right?
So working on scripts, working on code,
working on editing, working on lighting,
working on, so I focused on the videos.
There's business development, you know,
all the pipeline of people coming in.
There's marketing and Seo.
That's stuff I've had to do. But I'm,
you know, hiring people to work on that.
And so I just focused on the video content
and I work until maybe six or 7:00 PM
every day.
Um,
and then I kind of just shut off because
I'm in this for the long run. Okay.
So people like Elon Musk and you know,
a lot of very successful people will say,
you gotta be working a hundred hour
weeks. And you know what? I don't agree.
I don't agree with that because listen,
we're, we're hearing this life, right?
And it's a very short life and we don't
know what the point of everything is.
And there's more to life and
solving problems. Right? You got to,
I'm in this for the long run.
I don't want to burn out.
That's why I'm not working nights and days
every single day. Right. I'm trying to,
so what I do actually, um, um, is
I've been turning off my phone,
like on airplane mode at night.
So like at like 9:00 PM I'll just turn
it off and upset up until midnight when I
go to sleep, I'll just have my phone on
airplane mode. And then that way, um,
I'm just, you know, in my bubble in
my zone and I found that, that, that,
that was healthy for me. Um, and
also it's good for sleep as well. So,
and I actually,
I don't turn my phone off of airplane
mode until I get back to the spy coworking
space. I don't turn it so, so, so that's
like a, uh, a work flow. So yeah, exactly.
Work Smarter, not harder and
that, that definitely has helped.
Uh,
let's see what else we got.
I'm going to do this for nine more
minutes. I want a 30 minute live,
live stream Q and a.
Uh,
I don't have another phone that my
mom can call me on. No, no. So, so,
so there is some cons so there
could be an emergency. Um,
but uh, yeah, I might have to
work on something like that.
What is better for Mohammed asks,
what is better for a better future
ml or block chain machine learning?
Listen, guys, blockchains grit.
It's an amazing technology. Um,
I talk about it a lot. I wrote a book
on it. I'd go to events about it,
but really it's just a tool.
It's like the skeleton of the brain
and the brain is machine learning.
Ai Is the truth and the light
is the answer. It is the,
it is the end goal and everything
else is a distraction. Okay.
Everything else is a distraction.
And you might be thinking, well,
you know blockchain's hot
and yes it is and yet,
well I can make a lot more money doing
block chain. It's actually about the same.
But let me tell you this,
AI is not going to die anytime soon.
Okay. Because think about it, you know,
a lot of people are saying, oh
well the, the hype might be dying.
It might be going up. You know, who
knows? It's just a bubble we're in.
There are so many industries that these
people had not even begun to think about
how AI can be applied to their
business use cases. Okay.
Agriculture supply chain, every
single industry, entertainment,
anything. So the, the problem
right now is a, is a, is a,
is a problem of application. The
technology exists. Not Enough people are,
have the technical knowhow to apply it
to these business use cases. So that's,
that's a real problem. Uh, next new asks,
are you Muslim? No, I
am not religious at all.
Although the closest thing to religion
would be, Hey, I, I'm also not Hindu,
although my parents are. Um,
Anthony, I love you too. A moron.
Husks. You're white hair is real.
No, it's not. I dyed it, uh, it,
but it is definitely a part of my logo.
G Magliochetti a beautiful Italian name.
I've actually been reading the Godfather
and by the way, amazing book. I mean,
I saw the movie like a decade ago,
but I've been reading it and cooking a
lot of Italian. I was recently in, um,
near Italy. I was near Halloween. I love
the Mediterranean. Such a beautiful,
beautiful culture, a beautiful
food. Um, and uh, yeah.
Okay.
Uh, all the Indians are going crazy. No,
it's all good guys. Listen, um, you know,
I'm American. I'm Indian. I'm both,
most of the kind of European guy lived
in Europe for your, I'm, I'm global.
I'm beyond that. I'm beyond all
that. Anyway. What was I saying? Um,
I will come back to India
though, by the way. You know,
I, I'm coming back, not back,
but like I visited, um, I was born in
the states anyway. World Baby. Exactly.
It's all, it's all good.
You know, White, black,
Brown, Puerto Rican or Asian. It don't
matter who you are. We want AI nation.
You hear what I said? Wasn't that a sick
rap? I just made that right now. Um,
can sensitive data. So city
casks, can sensitive data
be secure on the blockchain?
Um, yes. Well No. Okay, well,
yes you can put data
encrypted on the blockchain,
but the better thing to do would be 2.2.
It's on the blockchain.
So story in an encrypted
way in some decentralized
stories like IPFS store j Sia
and it points to that Hash in blockchain.
So well he would actually push to
the blockchain is your, um, is the,
is the content address. Um, Marco asks,
how important are social
skills for programmers,
social skills for programmers who are
employed at a company they can be useful
for dealing with the bureaucracy
and getting your ideas out there.
Social skills for freelance
programmers are supremely useful.
You guys have no idea. You are
constantly doing business development,
getting clients,
convincing them to let you work for them,
convincing them to let you have access
to their sensitive data that you want to
train their models on.
You have to build a brand.
Social skills are so
important in this week.
I had three videos coming out on this so
I know how much you guys need this and
want this and I've been listening. I had
been listening, okay, I am listening.
I am yours. Okay? I belong
to you guys. I am your slave.
I will do whatever you guys need me
to do. You know, but no one else,
you guys know company owns me, but
my community does own me. Google TPU.
What do you think? Amazing technology.
They actually go with Google cloud.
They made this democratize
and accessible to everybody.
So I would definitely check out tps.
Okay.
Um, is tendermint production
ready? COSMO's production ready?
It is production ready. Let me, let me
be clear. Is it production ready? Yes.
Is it ready to scale to
Facebook level ready? No. Okay.
So it's like halfway there,
but I know engineers working on the
team and they say by the end of the year
that it will be something that is like
that. Should you start building? Yes.
Should you wait for it to
be production ready? No.
Does this apply to every technology?
Yes.
You shouldn't be waiting for anything in
the blockchain or AI space to be ready
in terms of, let's just be real ready in
terms of blockchain meets scalable. Okay.
Ready? In terms of blockchain means scale.
This is a beef jerky by the way. Oh,
it's some good stuff.
I love beef Jerky,
which is okay as k husks
say something in Hindi. MMM.
MMM.
Okay.
Um, what's it like a Bollywood
Song? A through j day. God,
I know. It's very cliche. So that's
doesn't mean be for you guys.
I can also speak other languages
as well. Right? This is not how,
I don't have to just show love to Indians,
which I love too,
but there's other people out there, right?
So say something in Dutch. Um, uh, so
pull hot debt, uh, and
uh, of course ls and uh,
okay.
Yeah, real common in
natal. Okay. That's it.
I really didn't have a hard time
learning Dutch by the way when I lived in
Amsterdam,
but I'm back in San Francisco.
How does start with movidius
guys have a great video.
Obviously you know about this. Um, but
they have some great documentation.
So check out their website,
search to developer.mobidius.com
Depok says, please say Depok. So I'll
say, do you park three times for you?
Deep Party Party,
party?
What Texas universities you
considered excellent rep, reputable.
So my sister actually goes to
University of Texas, Austin.
She's actually getting a lot of people
talking to, are asking to come to me,
which is crazy because,
mmm.
Yeah. The things about being influential
people will reach out to your family.
Um, I say UTS. Cool. You know,
I never want it to go there because I
preferred Columbia and I needed to get out
of Texas asap. But um, in
terms of the best school in
Texas, it would be ut Austin.
If I had to go,
I'd go to ut Austin.
Best Linux distro is bound to the best.
Um,
winning sister was going to be the one
with the most developer activity and that
actually applies to a lot of technologies.
Like for example,
machine learning frameworks. What is the
one with the most developer activity?
Tensorflow,
what's the second most Pi torch and
what are the two best in that order?
Not Coincidentally tensorflow
and Pi Torch. Two minutes
left in this livestream.
Okay.
Alvaro Asks Best University in Florida.
USF
[inaudible] what did you do in high school
to pursue AI? I'll tell you right now,
zero what did I do in terms of technology?
In high school I was kind
of a black hat hacker.
I was like a 16 year old kid who got a
desktop PC and thought all those hackers
were cool or like breaking into systems
and like, you know, defacing forums.
It's very embarrassing for me to admit
now as an adult and you know more than a
decade later. But as a kid I would
like, I was a city script kitty.
I was just like find perl
scripts and like run them.
But that was like my first foray
into the old technology space space.
I would also mod halo two.
So I would like to hack into halo two and
like online games in general were very
fun for me to act.
So I would say gaming is a good,
I wouldn't say do anything bad, but
just kind of like gaming is a good way.
Fortnights is apparently very popular
these days. One Love was mine. Um,
so I would recommend looking to combining
fortnight and machine learning in some
way. And if you don't do it, I
definitely went with the video.
I might be talking very fast,
but that's because I'm just very
excited to see all the Marcos.
It's good to see you, man, love you. And
a lot of cool people in here. Wow. It did.
She has any error for touche. I'm
gonna say five. I'm going to, okay,
I'm going to answer one more question
and say five more names and then with the
wrap and amount. Okay. So the question is,
yeah.
Oh,
great question.
How long should I take to
learn reinforcement learning
given one is comfortable
with deep learning.
So got,
so reinforcement learning is actually
to me horror than deep learning.
Reinforcement learning is very hard.
Um,
and I did a course on this and
you search reinforcement learning,
Raj with innovations.
It's a great course.
It's on youtube in the form of a playlist.
But I would say that the hottest field
right now in machine learning and deep
learning is reinforcement learning.
Alphago, um, you know, the open AI five,
all the hottest advancements are
coming out from reinforcement learning.
How much time should you
spend on it should you spend
on it? I would say if you,
if you're familiar with deep learning,
that two months,
two months is a good amount of time.
Lastly,
a five names I'm going to mention just
randomly Mario, uh, with zeal Paul,
Call Hoon Chan, Wu Park, Sean Hansen,
and of course rich Paul Riddick
part. Okay, so, and lastly,
I'm going to wrap a little bit to
say it. Just say a, a freestyle rap.
So just stay a topic. I'll
pick one and go at it. Okay.
Okay.
Just say a topic, one word, one word
topic, and that freestyle rap comes out.
Hopefully it's machine
learning or AI related. Ready?
Uh,
okay.
Hey, I like to use a GPU. I do
it every day. I don't use a TPU.
I do it cause I see you in the
thought in my digit, in my destiny.
I see you in my mind. Can't you see I'm
back. I'm in San Francisco. I got it all.
I'm like a Frisco.
I'm frisky.
I do things this way and that do
livestreams and go back to probabilistic
programming,
stochastic models and other things
like backpropagation. All right.
That's it. All right. Dank.
Right. All right guys, uh,
thanks for showing up. I'm, I,
I'm going to start the live streams better
quality next week. Starting next week,
every single week. Um,
uh, love you guys. Uh,
you are the reason that I do this.
And by the way,
if there is some way you want to repay
me for all the work that I've been doing
with the videos, there's
only one thing. Okay?
I want you to teach other AI,
teach your friends AI,
make a blog post about AI. Speak
at a conference. Um, teach ar.
Don't just learn a,
I teach AI because teaching is the best
way to learn anything. Okay? With that,
so now I've got to
enter some comments.
So thanks for watching.